it's like strawberries on a summer
evening
and it sounds just like a song harry
styles you may take a bow
and the grammy goes to watermelon sugar
harry styles
[Applause]
not only did the 27 year old singer
delight us with his first ever
performance at the grammy awards
[Music]
harry also won his first ever grammy
award for best pop solo performance for
that very song watermelon sugar
wow to everyone
who made this record with me thank you
so much this was the first song
we wrote after the my first album came
out
while the audio dropped out for the last
section of harry's speech
viewers did watch him get some applause
from billy eilish and
another fellow nominee taylor swift who
dated harry in twenty twelve
[Music]
harry was decked out in a gucci leather
jacket and matching pants
but grammy's host trevor noah did have
one fashion critique
harry styles that was amazing man i mean
i would have worn a shirt for my first
grammys but you know
he's to his own the former member of one
direction was also nominated for best
pop vocal album and best music video for
adore you don't have to
[Music]
watermelon sugar is the fourth single
off his album
fine line this song became watermelon
sugar
it's probably the longest it's ever
taken me to
finish a song
[Music]
as harry tells it the song's name
watermelon sugar had some literary
inspiration we had this idea and we we
had
like this chorus melody and it just kind
of was pretty repetitive
and the richard brothergan book in
watermelon sugar was on the table
and i was like that sounds cool
[Music]